before was a world-famous restaurant The
Inn at little Washington was just a
rundown gas station in a town
fewer than 200 people now the rural
Virginia eatery is celebrating its 40th
anniversary Jan Crawford sat down with
the chef and founder she's at the
restaurant in Washington Virginia Jan
good morning well good morning so this
is where the magic happens and you know
in a world where diners are always
searching for the next hot thing it's
hard to imagine someone maintaining a
standard of excellence for 40 years much
less celebrating that milestone at the
home of one of our founding fathers but
chef Patrick O'Connell has never really
cared about chasing what's popular and
that's helped him accomplish what most
people said was impossible at George
Washington's historic Mount Vernon it
was a feast for the ages you don't turn
40 every year characters costumes even
fireworks
over-the-top celebration organized by a
man who has always dreamed big there is
no shortage and never will be of people
telling you why something won't work but
if you feel it in your gut there's a
great thrill in going against all the
negativity 70 miles west of Mount Vernon
in an historic town with less than 200
people Patrick O'Connell arrived in 1978
and turned a former gas station and
garage into the Inn at little Washington
what was your vision 40 years ago well
my mother always said I wasn't too well
grounded in reality but I say it has
served me well people thought he was
crazy this local boy who loved a cook
but never even went to cooking school
even his mother had doubts she said now
dear if things don't work out we could
always sell that wonderful granola you
make door-to-door
what's that encouraging I was so pissed
it's said O'Connell built a masterpiece
a two-star Michelin restaurant and
five-star hotel in rural Virginia that
attracts visitors from DC to Abu Dhabi
here we are entering the kitchen is
stepping into the middle of a well
choreographed ballet make a little green
risotto
after starting is the ends only cook on
opening night when dinner was for 95
O'Connell now oversees dozens of kitchen
staff with discipline and humor these
snails are fed on the basil where do you
get these snails from a very strange
person that humor can also be found in
the details cheese served on the back of
the cow we just milk it for all it's
worth
and chefs decked out in Dalmatian spots
in honor of the inn's mascot sit sit but
what's most remarkable is that O'Connell
found satisfaction with what was right
in front of him 40 years in this one
place all you have to do is whatever you
did yesterday try to make it a
teeny-weeny bit better today then that
builds a kind of momentum and with
success comes pressure to deliver well
nothing's ever perfect so there are
moments when something comes together
and you go yes and then you look to that
but that's not right but you can at
least let yourself have that moment but
he's not the kind of tyrannical chef
whose employees live in fear his are
like family director of dining services
neil o'hare has worked here 25 years now
alongside his sons including his oldest
michael i think you have to buy in two
chef's vision and which is perfection
but we're never gonna get there
O'Connell has transformed this little
town renovating dozens of historic
buildings many that stood when George
Washington first arrived here as a
teenager for decades spent bringing an
impossible dream to life dream the dream
you can always scale it back otherwise
you lose your ability to dream you know
fairy tales can come true you
transformed a place and created a
beautiful not without sacrifice you have
to
be willing to give something up in order
to do that you have to want it pretty
bad what did you give up life as you
know it this is your life yes yes yeah
so it's it's not a bad trade now over 40
years O'Connell's cooked in this kitchen
for everyone from presidents to movie
stars and he said he's not done yet
there are more buildings to renovate two
books in the works and a film project
with virginia public media that's going
to take viewers through the doors of his
kitchen and into this magical world Gale
Jan I loved chefs philosophy and he
clearly has a great sense of humor and a
very infectious laugh yeah I mean he was
so wonderful to talk to and yeah I could
imagine what he creates I could tell
amazing person thanks again I like to
sing about do what you did yesterday and
try to make it a little better and if
you stayed there you have dinner you
stay there and then the next morning
they serve breakfast and it's like
fresh-baked croissants and like all
these jams and jellies and bowls
yeah I like it Nora